[MUSIC]
We live in a world that is filled with so
much noise.
A 2018 Deloitte study said the average
American picks up their phone
52 times a day.
Now, you may be thinking and
doing the math, that's twice an hour,
that's not so bad.
But when you're factor in the time that
you're spending sleeping, eating, driving
a car, having sex, things you should all
be doing without a phone in your hand.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's really more [LAUGH] like once
every ten minutes.
When was the last time you voluntarily
turned off your phone for 24 hours?
48 hours?
I would say that the device in
your pocket, all the alerts,
the dings, the bings, the emails,
is keeping you from living your best life.
And I'm not talking about the Kardashian
best life, [LAUGH] I'm talking about
a life that is aligned intentionally
with your values and your desires.
Eight years ago,
I was not living my best life.
I was living a good life,
but it was not my best life.
I was leading two teams of 45 people,
creating 450 pieces of editorial content
each month, for 2 million Americans.
You might say I was contributing
to the content problem.
I was working 12 to 15 hour days trying
to manage those 45 direct reports.
And every morning I would
get up at 7:00 AM and
the first thing I would
do was check my phone.
I would then commute up to the city for
an hour, have a full day,
commute back down, have dinner,
get back on my laptop typing my emails.
And every night before I went to bed,
whether it was at 1:30,
2:00, 2:30, 3:00,
the last thing I did every night
was check my phone one last time, to see
if there was an email that I missed.
That same year, on a Saturday in October,
I had a Friday just like the Friday,
a day that I told you about.
I remember that I was tired,
but I still wanted to make that
drive to the city to get a drink
with my friend for her birthday.
I remember driving to the city, I remember
it was a cold San Francisco night.
Pretty much every night
in San Francisco is cold.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I remember huddling under the heat lamp
trying to get warm.
I remember feeling tired and
then I started to feel odd.
I started to feel really weird.
And I remember I walked over to the bar to
get a glass of water hoping that glass of
water would somehow make me feel better.
And the next thing I knew I
was on the floor of the bar.
I had fainted.
So this is the part of the story
where most people say this was
the turning point.
This is the moment that I realized
my life really needed to change.
That is not how this story goes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The next day we went to the doctor and
she said, you're a very normal healthy
26 year old except that you were
severely dehydrated and exhausted.
So I went and I fixed these two things.
I rehydrated myself,
I got a little bit more sleep, and
I went right back to my life.
My over-worked, exhausted,
tech-addicted life.
Those next eight years are really intense.
We nearly ran out of money twice,
that company I was telling you about.
We raised more money.
We sold that company to a much bigger
company, taking our 250-person
organization and trying to integrate
into this 250,000 person organization.
I left that company.
I ended a really important relationship.
But that year, that first year
that I was telling you about,
I began to practice that has
transformed the way I live.
That year, I began a practice of
retreating from my life in order to move
forward in my life, with greater
intention and greater purpose.
Every three months,
right after work on Friday,
I drive up into the California hills
into that beautiful golden place.
I go to my favorite retreat center,
Silence Day.
I get out of my car and let the beauty
in the silence begin to fill my soul.
But the thing that I do is I take
out my phone, and I turn it off, for
the next 36 hours, until Sunday afternoon.
This practice has grounded me
through the storms of life.
It has created space for me to simply be,
space to reflect on my life.
And it's given my brain 36 hours to
detach from my technology addiction,
helping my brain reset, just once.
So I want to invite you all to join me in
retreating from your life to move forward.
Maybe you're feeling like I did,
desperate, overworked.
Maybe for you it's being a parent,
that daily grind.
Maybe it's laundry,
chores, dishes, repeat.
Maybe it's the weight of figuring
out who you want to be right now and
who you want to be in the future.
Now, I know some of you are thinking,
Tiffany, this is crazy.
I can't take off 36 hours of my life.
I know the extroverts out there
are thinking, I can't be quiet for
2 hours much less 36 hours.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I know the parents are thinking,
I cannot abandon my co-parent for
the entire weekend.
They will kill me when I get back.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I have a challenge for
you, I'm calling it
the coffee shop challenge.
I invite you to take a small
tech detox of just two hours.
This weekend, this Saturday or
Sunday, go to a coffee shop and
turn off your phone for two hours.
And during that time you can do the three
things that I do whenever I go on my
retreats.
First, I turn off my phone.
You'll have already done that.
Two, I begin to reflect on the last
three months, not your whole life,
just the last three months.
What worked, what didn't?
What really sucked?
What do you want to do differently?
And then lastly, I pull out the list of
things I would love to do with my life,
and I choose one thing to do
in the next three months.
If you don't have that list, this weekend
is a perfect time to make that list.
We live in world that is filled with so
much noise.
Resist the urge to consume
more information and do more.
Instead, turn inwards.
My senior year at Stanford,
I remember reading this line that
has stuck with me to this day.
Richard Foster in the Celebration of
Discipline said, the desperate need in our
world today is not for more gifted or
intelligent people but for deep people.
I'm going to say it again.
The desperate need in our world today
is not for more gifted people, or
intelligent people, but deep people.
Friends, you are some of the most
gifted and intelligent people I know.
And your life challenge will be to figure
out what is your gift to the worlds.
But before you lead others, before you
change lives, change organizations and
change the world, I want to invite you
all to begin by changing yourself.
That starts by turning off your phone and
turning inwards.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]